foreign
digital marketing involves promoting
products or Services through digital
channels such as social media email
search engines and websites It utilizes
data and analytics to Target specific
audiences optimize campaigns and measure
success the goal is to increase brand
awareness generate leads and ultimately
Drive sales through online channels a
digital marketer creates and executes
digital marketing campaigns that meet
business objectives they use a variety
of digital channels such as social media
email search engines and websites to
reach and engage with target audience
they also analyze data and adjust
strategies to optimize campaign
performance and drive results digital
marketers have a huge demand in the
industry according to LinkedIn a senior
digital marketing director earns one
hundred five thousand dollars a
mid-level digital marketing manager
earns seventy thousand dollars and a
fresher digital marketer earns fifty two
thousand dollars annually whether it is
an I.T firm or a food industry digital
marketers are playing a key role Brands
like Accenture Deloitte IBM fortura
Apple Intel meta Etc a hiring digital
marketers with competitive salaries so
are you looking to get hired by one if
yes then let me present you with simply
learns post graduate program in digital
marketing in collaboration with Purdue
University and meta blueprint this
course is the perfect package if you are
looking to get certified in digital
marketing you will gain all the
necessary skills in digital marketing
like search engine optimization content
marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
management and optimization URL
management search psychology keyword
organization and match types keyword
research Advanced ad features ad testing
and extensions and much more with this
you will gain hands-on experience with
the tools like SC ranking social media
apps like Facebook Instagram LinkedIn
YouTube Twitter learn Google ads Google
tag manager Google Keyword Planner
Google data studio YouTube analytics and
more so hurry up and enroll Now find the
course Link in the description box so
without any further Ado let's start by
knowing how to become a certified
digital marketer to become a digital
marketer you should be great with skills
and good certification from a reputed
firm will be a cherry on the cake here
are the top 10 ways to become a
successful digital marketer number one
learn digital marketing fundamentals
start by learning the basics of digital
marketing such as SEO social media email
marketing and content marketing next we
have is build a portfolio create a
portfolio showcasing your work and
digital marketing skills include case
studies sample campaigns and any
relevant projects you have worked on
next we have is you should gain
experience look for the internships or
entry-level jobs in digital marketing to
gain hands-on experience and learn from
the industry experts next we have is
strong networking a 10 attend industry
events and join online communities to
connect with other digital marketers and
stay up to date on industry Trends stay
updated digital marketing is constantly
evolving so make sure to stay updated by
reading industry blogs taking courses
and attending webinars next we have is
have a specialization considering
specializing in a specific area of
digital marketing such as SEO social
media or PPC to become an expert in your
field next we have is practice analytics
digital marketing is all about data so
becoming comfortable with analytics
tools like Google analytics is important
learn how to track key performance
indicators or kpis and use data to make
informed decisions develop technical
skills digital marketing involves a lot
of technical skills such as HTML CSS and
WordPress learning these skills can help
you to stand out and make you more
effective in your role next we have is
to get certified considering getting
certified in digital marketing to
enhance your skills and improve your
resume certification from a reputed form
will enhance your visibility among the
top recruiters simply learn Spurs
graduate program in digital marketing is
among the best digital marketing
certifications online find the course
Link in the description box and the next
and the last one we have is keep a
growth mindset the digital marketing
landscape is constantly changing so it
is important to maintain a growth
mindset and be open to learning new
skills and strategies stay curious and
don't be afraid to experiment with new
ideas hope you got a good knowledge
about the topic if you have any queries
feel free to add them in the comment
sections and our expert will revert back
to you if you like this video subscribe
to Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates thanks for
watching this video
this video subscribe to the simply
learned YouTube channel and click here
to watch similar videos turn it up and
get certified click here
foreign